[Music]
this morning we are tracking the very
close vote count in the presidential
election
we are also looking at the president's
claims claims without any any evidence
anyone has seen so far
that democrats are in his words quote
trying to rig
an election here is part of what the
president said last night
at the white house we think we will win
the election very easily we think
there's going to be a lot of litigation
because we have so much evidence so much
proof and
it's going to end up perhaps at the
highest court in the land
we'll see again no one has seen that
evidence no it has seen that proof
joining us now
is cbs news contributor david becker he
is an election law expert and the
founder of the center for election
innovation and research
and perhaps one of the only election
experts in america not currently working
for one of the two campaigns
david very glad to have you with us this
morning
i want to go into some of the state by
state claims from the white house but i
want to begin big picture
the president says if every quote legal
vote is counted he'd win we just also
heard mitch mcconnell
uh say that legal votes should be
counted what is the legal definition of
a quote legal vote
well it varies by state but one thing we
know for sure is that all of the ballots
that are being counted right now
are legal if you look at a place like
pennsylvania we're not even into the
period of time where we're looking at
the ballots that were
mailed on election day and might have
arrived during the next three days
all of the ballots that were being
reported in pennsylvania were received
by election officials out of the hands
of voters
on election day or earlier so that's
what we're seeing out of pennsylvania
every legal vote
is being counted and we're seeing that
regardless of whether it's in
pennsylvania where there's a democratic
secretary of state
or in georgia or nevada where there are
very good republican secretaries of
state this is a bipartisan
success story about election
administration most of the lawsuits from
the trump campaign
are pretty small potatoes they do not
involve a large number
of votes the number of votes that could
actually swing something however in
nevada there is a more significant claim
of
improper voting from people who do not
actually reside
in the state what kind of evidence
because again we have seen
none so far no one has presented
anything what kind of evidence would be
required
to make that case in a court of law well
first of all we have seen no evidence of
this and something that's very important
to remember is they're basing this based
on some
analysis they claim of the voter files
of the voter list those voter lists are
public
they have been public forever in nevada
they could have had these
months ago they could have done this
analysis months ago they could have
tried to get voters invalidated at any
time during this year or last year or
any of the previous four years
and they did not do that the only reason
they're bringing it now is because
they're losing in nevada
there still remains no evidence of any
improprieties in nevada and again i want
to stress this
a very good republican secretary of
state barbara sagaski
who is running elections in nevada there
was another comment that the president
made
last night at the white house that i
want to get your reaction to it was
regarding
what he termed interference from big
media big money and big
tech interference is a legal sounding
term is there some sort of case that
could be built by a good lawyer
alleging interference in this election
well
i can't imagine there is but remember
also the one election where we have
extensive evidence of interference
by foreign adversaries and others is the
2016 election
which president trump won and where we
know and republicans and democrats have
agreed and his
own department of homeland security and
intelligence community have agreed
that the russians interfered on behalf
of president trump in that election
and we're seeing still some
disinformation campaigns
in this election however there's no
evidence that they were there to
uh to to hurt president trump and in
fact
had any effect on the election in terms
of how people voted
david quickly there are still a lot of
raw memories about the decision in 2000
by the supreme court
court halting a recount in florida
effectively handing the election
to president bush how likely is it this
time around that the supreme court could
intervene in some way that is decisive
well the president seems to think this
is a lot more like 2000 but it's
actually a lot more like 2016.
in 2000 what we saw is extremely
competent teams of lawyers go down to
florida and develop
facts over a long period of time and
then develop legal claims based on those
facts in one state that delivered the
presidency which
in which there was a margin of only 537
votes this is a lot different we're
seeing the president making
some unsubstantiated claims excuse me
all over the country in multiple states
where there's multiple
where the margins are much much greater
yeah if there is evidence we would want
to see it but we have not
seen any yet david becker thank you very
much